SAN JOSE SHARKS.
>>>TRAVIS.
RISTOLAINEN BY CONECHNY AND BACK
OUT TO CENTER. GORDANO, HE WILL
CE FROM
CAM ATKINSON.
AND A NEW-COMER TO PHILADELPHIA,
NOT THE NHL, HE IS HIT HARD, BU
BACK UP.
GOOD SHOT,SCORE.
VAN SLOT.
QUICK SHOT. WENNBERG AND MORGAN
FROST NOW WILL CLEAR IT TO
CENTER.
MORGAN, THE BENCH
PERIOD.
1-0 FLYERS.
GOURDE WITH A SHOT, NO PROBLEM
FOR MARAR ALEXANDER JOHNNY T THE
IN T
CLAUDE GIROUX, AND KELLYGIORDAN,
JARNKROK, ABLE TO USE THE
DEFENDER, AS THE BIT OF THEOPPO.
>> BACK HANDER, STOPPED BY
GRUBAUER.
AND YANDLE, THIRD
PERIODS.
JARNKROK, TOOK THE DRAW FOR
JARM LAUZON FROM DOWNTOWN,
TRAFFIC OUT IN FRONT.
JADE
>> NOT SURE IF HE GOT A PIECE O
CREATED, THAT PROBABLY IS THE V
REVIEW, IT'S DETERMINED THERE'S
GETS OUT.
MAKING SURE THAT HE IS GOING TO.
LOOKOUT.
RIEMSDYK, FINDS HIS
WAY, SNEAKS OFF TO THE FAR SIDE,
BROWN
CASINO.
SEATTLE LOOKING FOR THE FIRST E.
FRESH BODIES OUT FOR THE IT OF .
WAPROVOROV, WINS IT IN